FROM UKRAINE.
CNN'S NICK PATON WALSH IS ON THE
GROUND IN THE WAR ZONE.
>> Reporter: HIS BIGGEST
STATEMENT SINCE HE BEGAN THE WAR
THAT HE STILL WON'T CALL A WAR
DELAYED 12 HOURS TILL THIS
MORNING AND PERHAPS LESS DRASTIC
THAN FEARED, BUT STILL A HUGE
MOVE BY VLADIMIR PUTIN WHO UNTIL
NOW USED THIS SORT OF VOLUNTEER
RECRUITMENT PROCESS DECLARING
THE FIRST FORCED MOBILIZATION IN
RUSSIA EVEN IF IT IS PARTIAL
SINCE WORLD WAR II.
[ SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH ]
>> Translator: I REPEAT, WE ARE
TALKING ONLY ABOUT PARTIAL
MOBILIZATION, IN OTHER WORDS,
ONLY MILITARY RESERVISTS
PRIMARILY THOSE WHO SERVED IN
THE ARMED FORCES AND HAVE
SPECIFIC MILITARY OCCUPATIONAL
SPECIALTIES AND CORRESPONDING
EXPERIENCE WILL BE CALLED UP.
>> Reporter: BEHIND IT ALL THE
NUCLEAR THREAT.
CLAIMING THE WEST HAD THREATENED
RUSSIA AND SO RUSSIA WOULD USE
EVERYTHING IT HAD TO DEFEND ITS
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY.
>> Translator: THIS IS NOT A
PLOUFFE.
THE CITIZENS OF RUSSIA CAN BE
SURE THAT THE TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY OF OUR HOMELAND, OUR
INDEPENDENCE AND FREEDOM WILL BE
ENSURED.
I EMPHASIZE THIS AGAIN WITH ALL
THE MEANS AT OUR DISPOSAL AND
THOSE WHO TRY TO BLACKMAIL US
WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS SHOULD KNOW
THAT THE PREVAILING WINDS CAN
TURN IN THEIR DIRECTION.
>> Reporter: THE MOBILIZATION IS
A HUGE UNDERTAKING ANALYSTS SAID
WHEN THEY'VE ALREADY FAILED TO
SUPPLY, EQUIP AND EFFECTIVELY
DEPLOY THEIR REGULAR ARMY OVER
THE PAST SIX MONTHS.
IT WILL NOT BE QUICK.
>> Translator: 300,000
RESERVISTS WILL BE CALLED UP.
I WANT TO SAY STRAIGHTAWAY THIS
WORK WILL NOT BE CARRIED OFF AS
A ONE-OFF BUT IN A SYSTEMIC
PLANNED MANNER AS I'VE ALREADY
SAID.
>> Reporter: UNEASE PALPABLE ON
MOSCOW STREETS.
EVEN IF PROTESTS WAS AS USUAL,
MUTED AND SUPPRESSED.
YOU ALWAYS FEEL WORRIED IN
MOMENTS LIKE THIS, HE SAID,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A WIFE AND KIDS
AND YOU THINK ABOUT THAT.
I WOULD NOT WANT TO LEAVE THEM
IN CASE SOMETHING HAPPENS.
THE BIG QUESTION, AMID ALL THE
RHETORIC AND THREATS OF
ESCALATION, IS DOES THIS CHANGE
MATTERS ON THE GROUND?
STILL, UKRAINE PUSHES FORWARDS
DESPITE SLIGHT RUSSIAN GAINS
AROUND THE AREA.
RUSSIA STILL STRUGGLES TO MATCH
ITS STATUS AS A NUCLEAR POWER
WITH REAL PROGRESS AND STRATEGY
ON THE GROUND.
PUTIN'S BID TO APPEAR STRONG
PERHAPS A REMINDER OF HOW WEAK
THIS WAR OF CHOICE HAS LEFT HIM.
WOLF, WE ARE INTO A BREAKNECK
WEEK LIKELY HERE IN UKRAINE.
RUSSIA HAVING CALLED THROUGH ITS
PROXIES IN THE REGION, FRESHLY
OCCUPIED AREAS FOR FOUR SEPARATE
REFERENDA WHICH WILL ESSENTIALLY
BY EARLY NEXT WEEK PROBABLY COME
UP WITH A VERY POSITIVE FIGURE
SUGGESTING THAT EVEN THOUGH
THESE VOTE, SHAM VOTES WERE HELD
UNDER CONDITIONS UNDER MILITARY
OCCUPATION, THAT PEOPLE LIVING
THERE WANT TO BE PART OF RUSSIA.
THAT MAY THEN CAUSE MOSCOW TO
SAY THAT THESE OCCUPIED AREAS OF
UKRAINE, THEY ESSENTIALLY
RECOGNIZE AS PART OF THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION.
THERE'S A LOT OF PRESSURE ON
UKRAINE IN THE COMING WEEK TO
POSSIBLY MAKE SOME KIND OF
TERRITORIAL ADVANCES HERE TO TRY
TO DISRUPT THE SHAM VOTING
PROCESS PERHAPS.
BUT WE HEARD MOSCOW TRYING TO
RECONTROL THE NARRATIVE THAT
SLIPPED OUT OF ITS HANDS AFTER
EXTRAORDINARY UKRAINIAN ADVANCES
OVER THE PAST WEEKS, BUT
PROBABLY ESSENTIALLY REMINDING
PEOPLE HOW FAR THEY'VE SLIPPED
OVER THE PAST WEEK, WOLF.
>> NICK PATON WALSH FOR US IN
UKRAINE, THANK YOU VERY, VERY
MUCH.
WANT TO BRING BACK KAITLAN
COLLINS AT THE UNITED NATIONS
ALONG WITH CHIEF NATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT SHIM SCIUTTO,
RETIRED U.S. ARMY GENERAL WESLEY
CLARK, THE FORMER NATO SUPREME
ALLIED COMMANDER NOW A CNN
MILITARY ANALYST AND THE FORMER
U.S. AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE,
WILLIAM TAYLOR.
JIM SCIUTTO, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY'S VERY FORCEFUL SPEECH
JUST DELIVERED BEFORE THE UNITED
NATIONS GENERAL ASSEMBLY.
HE'S DEMANDING RUSSIA BE
PUNISHED FOR ITS AGGRESSION
AGAINST UKRAINE.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF HIS
REMARKS?
>> IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME HE'S
DEMANDED CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
RUSSIAN LEADER FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY, BUT
IT'S NOTABLE TO ME COUPLED WITH
UKRAINE'S RAPID ADVANCE AND ITS
COUNTEROFFENSIVE IN THE NORTH
THAT THE CALCULUS HAS CHANGED IN
THIS WAR, THAT HE IS NOW LOOKING
AHEAD TO A POINT WHERE NOT ONLY
DOES RUSSIA NOT WIN IN UKRAINE,
THAT RUSSIA LOSES IN UKRAINE,
UKRAINE SUCCESSFULLY DEFENDS ITS
TERRITORY, BUT THAT RUSSIA THEN
FACES CONSEQUENCES FOR IT BEYOND
THE LOSS OF ITS STRATEGIC
OBJECTIVES.
YOU'VE HEARD THAT FROM EUROPEAN
OFFICIALS, NATO OFFICIAL, U.S.
OFFICIALS THAT THEY'VE LOST
THEIR STRATEGIC AIMS IN UKRAINE
AND YOU SEE THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT PERHAPS EMBOLDENED BY
MILITARY SUCCESSES ON THE GROUND
AS WELL AS INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT
TO BE ABLE TO GAZE FOO THE
FUTURE AND THAT MAY BE MONTHS OR
EVEN YEARS GIVEN RUSSIA'S
MOBILIZATION BEFORE THE WAR IS
OVER BUT TO GAZE INTO THE FUTURE
AND SAY, HE NEEDS TO PAY FOR
THIS, RIGHT, SO THAT THIS DOES
NOT HAPPEN AGAIN EITHER BY PUTIN
OR OTHER LEADERS WHO THINK THEY
CAN GET AWAY WITH TERRITORIAL
EXPANSIONISM AT THE POINT -- AT
THE END OF A GUN.
>> VERY STRONG REMARKS FROM
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, INDEED.
GENERAL CLARK, LET ME GET YOUR
REACTION.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY'S SPEECH
COMES AFTER THIS VERY
SIGNIFICANT ESCALATION FROM THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT PUTIN TODAY.
IS THE RUSSIAN LEADER FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE GROWING INCREASINGLY
DESPERATE RIGHT NOW PERHAPS
INCREASINGLY DANGEROUS AT THE
SAME TIME?
>> WELL, YES, HE IS DESPERATE
AND THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN SOME
RISK OF HIS USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, BUT THE 300,000
MOBILIZATION, THAT'S A PROBLEM
FOR MONTHS, AND HE DOESN'T HAVE
THE EQUIPMENT FOR THEM IN ANY
CASE WHEN THEY'RE MOBILIZED SO
THAT'S REALLY WHAT HE'S COVERING
UP WHEN HE THREATENS WITH
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
HE KNOWS THAT THESE -- USE OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IS NOT GOING TO
END THIS CONFLICT FOR HIM.
IT'S GOING TO DEEPEN THE
CONFLICT.
BUT HE'S AFTER THE SHOCK EFFECT
OF THE THREAT.
HE'S AFTER TRYING TO DETER
NATIONS SITTING ON THE SIDELINE
FROM COMING IN AGAINST HIM, AND
HE WANTS TO WEAKEN THE WESTERN
RESOLVE TO ASSIST UKRAINE AND
CONVERSELY, WHAT HE'S DOING IS
GOING TO STRENGTHEN WESTERN
RESOLVE AND PROBABLY ACCELERATE
THE FLOW OF WESTERN ARMAMENTS TO
UKRAINE.
>> YEAH.
>> SO, ONCE AGAIN, HE'S GETTING
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
HE'S SEEKING.
>> I SUSPECT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
AMBASSADOR TAYLOR, PRESIDENT
BIDEN TODAY REITERATED THAT U.S.
SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE IN HIS WORD
IS UNWAVERING.
DURING HIS SPEECH AT THE U.N.
TODAY, HOW IMPORTANT WAS IT FOR
UKRAINE AND FOR THE WORLD FOR
THAT MATTER TO HEAR THAT MESSAGE
SO LOUDLY AND CLEARLY COMING
FROM THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES?
>> WOLF, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THE UKRAINIANS HEAR THAT.
THEY KNOW THAT THE UNITED STATES
IS WITH THEM.
THEY KNOW THE UNITED STATES HAS
BEEN THE MAIN SUPPLIER OF THE
WEAPONS THAT GENERAL CLARK JUST
TALKED ABOUT.
THEY KNOW THAT THAT HAS BEEN
DECISIVE IN THEIR SUCCESS IN
THESE COUNTEROFFENSES IN
PARTICULAR AROUND KHARKIV SO THE
UKRAINIANS KNOW THE VALUE OF THE
U.S. SUPPORT AND TO HEAR
PRESIDENT BIDEN REQUIRE THAT AND
CONFIRM THAT AND REASSERT THAT
IS VERY GOOD FOR THE UKRAINIAN
MORALE.
>> CERTAINLY S YOU KNOW,
KAITLAN, YOU'RE THERE AT THE
U.N. AND REPORTING THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT
NECESSARILY ENTIRELY SURPRISED
BY RUSSIA'S BOLD ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY.
HOW DID THAT INFLUENCE THE
PRESIDENT'S REMARKS AT THE
GENERAL ASSEMBLY?
>> YEAH, THEY WEREN'T REALLY
THAT CAUGHT OFF GUARD.
YOU CAN GUETTA SENSE SINCE YOU
SAW THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER JAKE SULLIVAN COME OUT
YESTERDAY AND TALKED ABOUT THE
SHAM REFERENDA THEY'VE BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT SAYING WE
BELIEVE THIS IS SOMETHING IN
RUSSIA'S PLAYBOOK AND THEY WILL
DO SO IT DIDN'T AMOUNT TO THIS
BIG REWRITING OF THE SPEECH.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW HOW MANY IT WAS
GOING TO BE AND WHAT HE WAS
GOING TO CALL FOR, BUT THEY KNEW
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS AN
OPTION FOR HIM.
I THINK TWO THINGS TO WATCH,
WOLF, AS YOU KNOW, THE NUCLEAR
COMMENTS THAT PRESIDENT PUTIN
MADE, THE WHITE HOUSE HAS KIND
OF BEEN DOWNPLAYING THAT SAYING
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY ACTION
BEHIND THE SCENES TO MATCH THE
RHETORIC PUBLICLY YET BUT, OF
COURSE, WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT
PUTIN'S NEXT MOVE IS GOING TO
BE, THAT'S SOMETHING THEY'RE
WATCHING BECAUSE HE IS CLEARLY
REALIZING AT HOME JUST H